one of the big things about quantum
break is the junction points yes right
sort of the big decisions you have to
make yeah which are equally
disadvantageous in the spirit of
junction points yes I'm going to pose a
series of questions for you okay
of all two different scenarios okay
explain which one you pick and reason
okay I'll try so let's start with one
from quantum break okay so would you
rather have your arch-nemesis kill a
bunch of college kids that everyone
knows you're a hero or have your
arch-nemesis killed no one but stage a
Fiat coverable it makes you everyone
hate you forever right I I would choose
the PR campaign yeah especially
considered we're playing a video game
yeah because Jack Joyce has special
abilities and I don't think I'd want
anybody innocent to get hurt in the in
the wake of making decisions so yeah I
would allow Jack Joyce to deal with Paul
serene in his way he's got special
abilities got super powers so that's
what I would do I think about real-life
process okay would you rather work a
cushy the menial office job and have the
whole world around you freeze for an
hour and we kind of check the time or be
respected food critic but your shameful
secret is everything you can seem taste
like ice and your life is a lie oh wow
I think I would oh that's so hard
neither one of them are good I'm gonna
say the food critic because a menial
desk job to me would be the worst
especially when time froze yeah yeah
yeah that would be horrible like an hour
or I'm sitting around just like
twiddling my thumbs like what do I do
now all right would you rather have time
vision powers so you could see people
through walls
okay but you're constantly aware of when
everyone around you needs to go to the
bathroom or live in otherwise ordinary
life but every time you sneeze you more
than pull possum for 30 minutes Oh
again another tough decision I'm gonna
say the possum okay only because it
might be really unique is it an until I
do I have my brain capacity at every
brain capacity okay so I could like run
around and do things as a possible yeah
okay yeah I'll do that okay every time
you sneeze sir I don't sneeze that off
okay would you rather have your twin
brother have unlimited access to time
manipulation powers okay but every time
he uses them you're frozen in ice and
you need to wait until it melts
okay or your the first thing with
awesome time in your place your house
but you can only eat lemon okay so side
question yeah how long does it take for
me to thaw out it just throws that
naturally so it can take an hour at a
time
okay let's go with that one so Aaron's
got time and installation powers yeah
and I get frozen and I have to wait I
would just we would have to have a deal
yeah like I would say like maybe once a
day
like once a week you can use this so
that would be like a negotiation between
him and I next one excellent okay
I do love lemons by the way what I also
love food I just couldn't rest of my
life so you can travel through time
would you rather I have to take off all
your clothes to do so meaning you're
always naked when you appear like I'm
like one like terminator okay or time
travel with your clothes on but every
time you open your mouth you only sound
out a sound that comes out
blood-curdling screams naked time travel
make good time yeah you can always find
clothes that's true
yeah good and just just time travel is
somewhere where you like the fashion
like don't go back to the 80s if you're
not into that fashion okay last one
would you rather have the potential I
have the potential to utilize any of the
fictional superpowers you've had during
your acting career in real life but you
have to eat your cell phone to activate
them eat my cell phone you eat yourself
okay like ingest it ingest it okay which
sounds deadly okay but you know you'd
have six hours yeah and also like the
summer or the only clothes are allowed
to wear on motion capture body see
motion captured bodysuit yeah so I can
use my time abilities but I have to wear
a motion capture suit no no no you'd
live an ordinary life but you have to
still yeah yeah eating my cell phone no
I'm not into that what would you do like
emerging captive stuff again would you
do something like once a break again
absolutely yeah I love the process and
once I figured out just the this sort of
broad strokes of what motion capture
takes it was amazing the first couple
days were really really tough not only
because you have to use your imagination
to create the whole environment that
you're in which is also sort of fun but
it takes a little while there's also
this sense of when we were first doing
it we have to wear these like head head
to helmets with like there's like a
little computer on the back of it and
it's got two cameras and four lights and
two microphones so when you're acting
with somebody you have this
whole apparatus in your face and it's
kind of distracting and it's hard to
connect with the other actor because
you've got all this stuff in your you
know peripheral vision but once once I
got past that it became kind of easy to
figure out so I would definitely do it
again I also like the world that you can
be in like motion capture takes it to
that next level so that you're not
limited by well we can only shoot in
this location like what they can they
can do create whatever they want around
you and when it breaks a perfect example
like you're in this like time machine or
you're interacting with these time
abilities like that's it's it's
incredible what detect where technology
can take us now
you